breaking tonight americans trying to
leave afghanistan are pleading with the
biden administration for help a number
of them are on charter planes still
being blocked from leaving the
administration is blaming the taliban
but not everyone is buying that
correspondent trey yinks starts us off
tonight from doha qatar hello trey
shannon good evening there is tension on
the ground in afghanistan as the taliban
cracks down on protests and civilians
try to flee
charter flights from afghanistan remain
grounded an estimated 100 americans are
still stuck in the country a handful of
them in the northern city of mazari
sharif they have planes but aren't
permitted to take off as of now
the taliban are not permitting the
charter flights to depart
they claim that some of the passengers
do not have the required documentation
while secretary of state anthony blinken
blamed the taliban for halted evacuation
flights a leaked email shows that some
aircraft are being denied takeoff by the
state department
a senior u.s official says there's no
way to vet who is boarding the planes
making the rescue missions susceptible
to terrorism with air traffic at a
standstill civilians and foreigners
continue to flee on foot
neighboring pakistan said it's already
deported around 50 families who crossed
into the country without proper
documentation
pakistani government will remain the
same no illegal immigrant will be
allowed to enter our country thank god
there hasn't been a huge influx of
refugees so far
for those afghans left behind they face
a taliban that is consolidating power
with the new government and cracking
down on opposition
protests erupted again in the afghan
capital of kabul as civilians demand
their rights be respected and their
country remains sovereign
taliban fighters responded by firing
their weapons in the air to disperse the
crowd the islamic government is shooting
at our poor people
these people are very unjust and they're
not human at all they do not give us the
right to demonstrate they're not muslims
but infidels as you can see the
situation we are in
there are efforts underway right now to
reopen kabul's international airport if
those talks with the taliban are
successful it could provide a way out
for some of those trapped shannon that's
good news trey yingst thank you very
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else